[Music]
yes I think the bathroom debate is
largely a distraction and based on
erroneous assumptions one of which is
the assumption that all trans women are
predators and that's not any more true
than the myth that existed 25 years ago
that all gay men are predators the
reality is most sexual predators are
cisgender straight men most women and
boys that experience sexual assault
growing up experience that at the hands
of a cisgender straight male perpetrator
the second erroneous assumption is that
transgender women are using the women's
restroom for any reason other than any
other woman would use the restroom right
they're simply using the restroom to
take care of bodily functions that we
all have and that myth or negative myth
or stereotype as trans women as
predators is not valid
there's virtually no data that documents
trans women attacking other women in
public restrooms it's simply not true
but it is used and being used to police
trans people and to attempt to legislate
transgender people out of existence in
many ways and to invalidate their
existence their right to exist in the
world alongside the same as anyone
else's right to exist it's also not very
workable right because as a transgender
man in some states I would be expected
to use the bathroom that matches my
biological sex but the reality is I
don't think many women would want would
feel comfortable in the women's room
with me there and there are trans men
all over the country and in all the
states that are looking at these laws or
enacting them who move through the world
being seen only as men who would be very
out of place in the women's room and
there are many many trans women who
moved through the world being seen as
women and would be very out of place and
at very high risk if they were to be
forced to use the men's room
so the reality is while there's this
guise of protecting women it's both not
effective in that in that it means men
like me would be using the women's room
and if it were really about protecting
women we'd see a whole slate of other
bills around discrimination against
women and women's bodies happening in
the public sphere being able to use a
bathroom that aligns with your firm
gender identity or gender presentation
is an absolutely critical issue for
trans people number one being able to
use the bathroom as a simple biological
need and function that we all have and
it's something that none of us should
have to think twice about it's something
that none of us should need an app in
order to find a safe bathroom for when
we're out in public it's something that
we should be able to take care of and
move on with our lives and not even give
a second thought to what we have instead
is transgender adolescents middle and
high school elementary school kids
adults not using the restroom all day
long at school because they're not
allowed to use the restroom that matches
their gender identity or gender
presentation and rather than experience
the gender dysphoria or the harassment
that comes with being in a restroom that
doesn't match their affirmed gender
they're choosing not to use the restroom
and there are medical risks physical
health risks associated with not using
the restroom for extended hours at a
time it's also a way of saying we don't
believe you are who you are so when
Gavin grim is told you can't use the
men's room at his high school
the underlying message he's being given
is we don't see you as a man we don't
believe you really are a man and that
kind of message is crazy-making for any
of us the reality is as human beings all
of us want to be seen for who we really
are we want to be acknowledged for who
our selves to be we want to be accepted
for who we are and love for who we are
by the people closest to us not in spite
of who we are and when someone young
trans man like kevin grimm is allowed to
use the men's room
what he experiences is an affirmation
that we respect we acknowledge you know
who you are as a young man
[Music]